il est là il arrive c'est le tout
nouveau smartphone deux fois jusqu'à 7
ou le tout nouveau smartphone de google
c'est le pixel 6 heures il existe deux
modèles cette année il ya un pixel si
c'est un pixel six pros
on est sûr de l espèce de cartons je
pense à carton recyclé ça écrit en tout
petit 5 g 7 6 ok 6 à 2 7 pouces noir
carbone 128 go de stockage pourrit tout
de suite cette vidéo de présentation va
être découpée en deux parties
aujourd'hui c'est elle a levé l'embargo
il ya deux embargo avec google cette
fois-ci première levée d'un embargo je
peux vous montrer le téléphone je peux
vous expliquer les fonctionnalités vous
expliquer qu est-ce qu il est à
l'intérieur cette nouvelle puce la
google tensor et appeler une chose là
bas donc s'en va le faire tout de suite
et la semaine prochaine on se donne
rendez vous il ya une deuxième levée
d'embargo cette fois ci sur les tests ou
l'âge pourrait tout vous montrer et vous
expliquer ce qu'on peut faire en
profondeur ça c'est pour les us et le
reste du monde en france on a
l'obligation qu'a les constructeurs ont
l'obligation de mettre des écouteurs
donc il faut mettre des petits écouteurs
de google qui sont juste ici et en fait
c'est exactement la même chose que vous
propose un peu c'est à dire un gros
fracas jing un peu moche mais celui là
est quand même beaucoup mieux que ce 2
d'apple et puis après vous avez le vrai
packaging le packaging cette fois-ci
google pixels six pros alors qu'est-ce
qu'on veut un geste design design il a
déjà été présentée on l'a vu donc même
si c'est nouveau je peux le prendre en
main mais il a déjà été vu et quelque
part ouverture facile donc ça c'est
pareil c'est un point qui est très très
bien haier ça j'aime bien alors regardez
on voit plein de choses intéressantes
cdu verts au dos et froid cdu-verts ces
sympathiques ces brillants donc je pense
qu'ici les traces de doigts 27 voix pour
l'instant je n'ai pas l'impression que
l'on prend des masses mais verra à terme
bien évidemment ce que j'aime bien voir
sur ce design déjà c'est que c'est
vachement différent par rapport à ce
qu'on peut retrouver sur le reste du
marché il ya un côté symétrie vous
pouvez le prendre au milieu vous le
coupez ya une vraie symétrie d'un côté
de l'autre ça c'est assez rigolo ce
qu'ils ont fait parce que là pour le
coup il ya un côté un peu plus mat sur
le dessus avec du brillant ici donc on
reste une fois de plus dans l'idée de la
symétrie et ça c'est assez marrant sur
le côté et bien c'est brillant aussi et
on voit ce module là qui se détache là
c'est un peu pro imminent mais bon
pourquoi pas ici pareil toujours en pd2
la symétrie avec les haut parleurs et
puis de la recharge chose que l'on
parlera ici devant le micro notre côté
tiroirs de cartes sim qui juste là quand
il ya une seule carte sim à l'intérieur
tac donc là déjà la première chose qu'on
voit c'est qu'on a accès à une seule
carte nanosims c'est une carte sim 5 g
ici qu'on peut voir venir un m pas
d'extension de mémoire pas double carte
sim vous n'avez pas de bloc de charges
inclues vous avez un câble en usb c'est
usb c'est on va retrouver quelques
petites docte ivoire de cartes sim
bouton de volume marché à reebok et
capteur d'empreinte digitale au centre
donc ça on va se regarder aussi on va se
configurer regardait déjà on le voit
tout de suite c'est la prise en main
c'est quand même un smartphone qui est
assez grand assez large alors on arrive
à faire le tour et à tenir comme ça on
est pas dans l'idée du smartphone un peu
plus petit assez compact après ici on
est sur l'écran de 6,5 pouces c'est une
très très grande dalle hop là google
waouh ça vibre il est légèrement incurvé
sur le côté l'écran mais très légèrement
je pense pas que ça pose de problème sur
la prise en main parce que mon doigt ne
va pas arriver complètement jusqu'à
cette partie là ça donne un peu plus de
profondeur lorsqu'on vient de regarder
j'aime bien welcome toujours pixels
alors non on est posée us mon lapin nous
on est en france ici c'est de
l'expérience 100% google 1 c'est du vrai
android 12 petit capteur d'empreintes
digitales pour venir déverrouiller
jacques s'est directement ici la
première chose qu'on voit cette grande
dalle on a un écran ltp aussi cette
poussée de l'oled avec un taux de
rafraîchissement qui va de diers ce
jusqu'à 120 hertz alors à quoi ça sert
me direz vous de passer de diers à 120
hertz et bien ça sert à économiser de la
batterie ça sert apporter plus de
fluidité sur des applications qui vous
permettront de le faire notamment
lorsque vous allez venir jouer un jeu
lorsque vous êtes sur un all ways and
display comme ce que j'ai tout de suite
ici vous il n'y a pas grand-chose qui
s'affiche eh bien vous arrivez sur du
d'hyères et le truc qui est intéressant
c'est comme celle oled tout ce qui est
noir ici ne consomme pas de batterie
donc ça permet d'économiser d'aller plus
loin dans sa c'est vachement bien alors
on a une grosse batterie 6 2 5 millions
période on a eu nos deux mecs nous
allons jusqu'à une journée complète 24
heures alors je veux bien mais c'est moi
qui la plupart des constructeurs nous
avons aujourd'hui un jour et demi
certains deux jours voire plus
l'autonomie ça jamais été le gros point
fort des pics est d'autant plus qu'elles
ont leur nouvelle puce qui s'appelle ya
tel sort premières puces invoquée par
google alors cette puce elle est
intéressante parce qu'elle montre deux
choses la première chose qu'elle vient
montrer c'est qu'ils s'émancipent de
qualcomm et puis le deuxième truc que ça
montre c'est que cette puce elle
fabriquée pour vous apporter meilleure
performance une meilleure autonomie donc
quand nous allons jusqu'à 24 heures
grâce à une nouvelle puce je me dis est
ce qu'en fait il ya un réel gars parer à
la tête mais ça laissez moi un petit peu
de temps pour venir le tester et un beau
retour dans quelques jours il est
compatible charge 30 watts alors il faut
venir acheter votre blog de charge 30
watts parce qu'ici voyez ça ne m'a pas
bayard n'a pas ça ne pas me faire de le
recharger en 30 minutes de 0 à 50 % et
il est compatible charge sans fil 12
watts autre truc qui est intéressant
c'est qu'à l'avant et à l'arrière passer
du vert vous avez vu corning gorilla
glass victime qui lui apprendra plus de
résistance et si aujourd'hui une vidéo
qui est réalisé en partenariat avec
rhino shit certes vous avez ici un
corning gorilla glass victime ce qui va
venir le protéger à l'avant et à
l'arrière mais c'est quand même bien de
permettre une protection en plus parce
que s'ils tombent sur des petits coins
un peu pointu ça peut venir l'endommager
d'où l'idée de venir protéger avec
l'école de mon partenaire rhinochill et
ça c'est une très bonne chose alors vous
avez des coques sherin au chili pour le
pixel 6 mais également pour le pixel six
pros on vient le mettre sur son
smartphone et ça vous fait ressortir le
module caméra que vous avez et la banque
ou votre dos est complètement protégé
donc ça c'est bien et ça permet aussi à
ses smartphones être un petit peu moins
glissant en main je vous l'avais
également pour finition carbone comme
ici sur le fixe l6 donc que vous
choisissiez un pic celle ci soit pixels
six pros eh bien vous avez de quoi faire
et puis vous avez encore plus de
collection chez rhino chine et notamment
aujourd'hui tout cas c'est intéressant
de tout nouveaux emballages en carton
encore plus éco-responsable en cours là
ce ne sont pas des coques pour le pixel
6 mai pour les iphone point fort ici on
est une nouvelle coque dragon ball z
league of legends et lancel elle est
hyper canon mais vous avez également des
bumper qui vont venir entourer votre
smartphone et vous laisser le dos dégagé
et si vous le souhaitez vous pouvez
venir customiser ici des backplate dans
différents univers ici pas canal c'est
bien pacman snoopy et vous avez
également des protections d'écran il y
en a de toutes les couleurs des voeux
impôts mais venir personnalisé ici les
boutons pouvait venir personnalisé
également le cadre intérieur vous avez
beaucoup de possibilités de
customisation sacchi vachement mais il
ya plein de licences disponibles
directement chez rhinochill perso
j'adore c'est hyper canon donc quelles
que soient vos goûts vos couleurs vous
trouvez votre bonheur chez rhinochill et
en plus de ça avec le code greu 21 vous
avez 5 % de remises offertes et ça s'est
super bien le lien est en bas dans la
description pour venir protéger votre
pixels six pixels six pros mais
également tous vos smartphones et même
voix et reposent ici vous avez de quoi
faire le lien une fois de plus est en
bas dans la description je vous parlais
de ce processeur le google tensor qui
apporte en théorie ce que nous annonce
google 80 % de performances en plus par
rapport aux pixels 5 donc on n'est pas
sur un gap de 30% comme ont pu avoir
d'une génération de qualcomm à une autre
lors des terrassements sur 80% ça veut
dire qu'il ya une vraie révolution là
d'ssus vous avez également un processeur
d'image sensor qui va venir optimiser le
traitement d'image lorsque vous allez
dire faire des photos dans la partie
photo on sent pas dans quelques instants
et puis vous avez également cette puce
titan l2 qui est là pour la sécurité qui
va travailler de pair avec le noyau de
sécurité de google tensor il ya une
interface sécurité on en parlera
également lors du test parce
qu'aujourd'hui tout de suite pas le
droit de vous le montrer truc que j'aime
bien sûr cette version et 6 et ses
icônes alors c'est de l'android 12,1
c'est un peu différent là on voit le thé
le tiroir d'applications vous avez de
l'intelligence artificielle en barquette
avec toute l'expérience google matériel
lui ou traduction instantanée cinq ans
de mise à jour de sécurité et vous avez
plein de fonctions sur la sécurité une
fois de plus on attendra la prochaine
fois pour lire désactiver votre micro
désactiver votre caméra il sort de venir
rassurer un peu tout le monde puisqu'on
parlait de la photo regarder on va venir
ici alors on va se rapprocher on a on le
voit ici trois parties trois capteurs
photo votre grand angle votre ultra
grand-angle et ici c'est un tel objectif
on nous annonce que notre grand temps
que de 50 méga pixels ici on va capter
150% de lumière en plus ce qui est
énorme pour des photos plus nettes et
plus vivent bon l'ultra grand temps de
12 mégapixels et pitt est l'objectif
zoom optique x 4 et on va jusqu'à un
zoom numérique x 30 une caméra de celle
fiq est planqué juste ici c'est un
grand-angle de 80 14 degrés histoire de
venir faire des photos de celle fille de
groupes de vous et vos amis il ya plein
de nouveautés au niveau de la partie
photo au niveau logiciel bah oui c'est
du google un bouffon du google ou point
de vue logiciel vous avez une pause
longue qui donnera un effet de mouvement
notamment si vous avez un liquide qui
s'écoule une rivière ou quelque chose
comme ça vous avez une gomme magique par
exemple vous avez une photo de vous de
vos amis peu importe avec au fond des
personnes qui sont incrustés vous voulez
les enlever et bien petite bonne machine
pouvait enlever très facilement ça ça
existait en ligne aujourd'hui ça se fait
orly ici directement dans vos
smartphones il ya également une
fonctionnalité anti-flou vous prenez une
photo par exemple de votre enfant ou de
je sais pas qui et hop la photo est
floue et bien petite fonctionnalité vous
enlevez le floor et puis une
optimisation au niveau des teintes de
peau pour pouvoir sortir des photos qui
vont être optimisé un smartphone qui est
certifié ip 68 résistants à l'eau et à
la poussière et regarder à ce qui est
marrant j'ai l'impression que cet écran
c'est un vrai miroir alors c'est noir
mais je me vois vraiment dedans à voir
ce que je remplace paul est ce que ça
posera un problème ou pas du tout et
c'est un smartphone qui coûte
199 euros c'est un vrai gars pain pour
google d'arriver ici avec le smartphone
a quasiment 900 euros on voit que les
smartphones monte en gamme alors on est
sur le modèle professionnel il existe un
modèle non professionnels le pixel
sicilia 649 là on à 899 je sais pas si
ça pourrait vous tentez vous d'aller sur
un smartphone de google a quasiment 900
euros est ce que ça vous plaira une fois
de plus on va attendre les résultats on
va regarder le texte mais s'il vous
intéresse à des pré commandes qui sont
intéressantes regarder joli tout de
suite et je mets les liens dans la
description alors laisser le temps à ce
que les liens apparaissent parce que
c'est sous embargo je publie à la lever
l'embargo je vous mets les liens
peut-être avec un petit décalage de
quelques heures mais si ça vous
intéresse vous avez les liens en bas
lors des trucs intéressants parce que
vous avez un abonnement de trois mois
offert à youtube premium ainsi que
google one et en plus de ça ils vous
offrent un casque de buzz c'est le boss
700 et c'est un excellent casque donc je
vous invite à venir vous abonner et
avant d'ici là poser toutes les
questions que vous avez sur le google
pixels six professionnels j'y répondrai
dans la prochaine vidéo donc allez-y en
bas en commentaire poser vos questions
je regarderai et les inclure et dans mon
test du google pixels six pros sur ce je
vous embrasse on se retrouve très vite
pour parler de ce smartphone parce que
c'est une vraie vraie vraie nouveauté
pour google d'arriver avec un smartphone
a quasiment 900 euros avec toutes les
promesses qu'il fait et ça c'est cool je
vous embrasse a très vite ciao
[Musique]